[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments are presented in the
olympian attempted murder trial you
should find michael barristone not
guilty all the same things that
established that the defendant wanted to
kill show
that he knew the nature and quality of
his actions plus the doomsday duo after
months of uncertainty an idaho judge
makes a shocking ruling and testimony in
the tote family murder trial my
sister-in-law was making a comment about
we just kind of put it all together
about basically the world ending on the
28th and nobody has talked to them but
first it's johnny depp versus amber hurd
we are live in fairfax county virginia
as opening statements are presented he
wanted out
which drove her to concoct to make up a
story that was at first
designed to keep him mr depp's team is
going to try to turn this case into a
soap opera lawn crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmart jurors and
johnny depp's defamation trial hear
opening statements as depp and his
ex-wife amber heard paint each other as
abusers and liars law and crimes angela
levy is live in virginia with more on
the arguments in the case anjanet
well brian this trial will be full of
salacious details about johnny depp
amber heard and their marriage both
claim that the other was physically
abusive during that brief marriage
johnny depp smiled as he walked into
court before opening statements began
he listened as his lawyers outlined why
he claims amber heard defamed him in
december of 2018 when she wrote an op-ed
in the washington post saying she had
become a public figure representing
abuse two years prior when she was
married to depp now her did not name
depp by name but he says that doesn't
matter that everyone knew heard was
referring to him he claims he lost
acting jobs because of that op-ed depp's
lawyers say the op-ed was timed to raise
heard's profile right before the release
of a film she was starring in which was
called aquaman depth denies herd's
claims of physical domestic and sexual
abuse
ms hurd as you know was an actress
when she accused mr deaf abuse and
painted herself before the world as a
representative of abuse victims
everywhere
miss heard took on the role of a
lifetime
she can't back down
she has been living and breathing this
lie for years now
and she has been preparing to give the
performance of her life in this trial
but this trial is about the evidence
it's about a man's reputation
and it's about his whole life
his ability to walk down the street
look people in the eye
without having to think he's an abuser
it's about the truth
and the truth will come out in this
trial
at the end of this trial
we will ask you to render a verdict for
mr death
we will ask you to tell the world that
he is not the abuser she described
but even amber heard's lawyers uh say
that johnny depp called himself the
monster and that he regularly abused
drugs and alcohol whether it was
prescription medication or illegal drugs
they say that depp actually blacked out
one time for three days while they were
in australia and held heard hostage
for three days and abused her at that
time the lawyers say that what amber
heard wrote in that op-ed is true and
therefore it's not defamatory
he was you know at times delusional
paranoid he would be you know mad at
somebody else then he'd be mad at her
and by the way we'll talk about the
prenup but he called her lawyer who she
had because she wanted to give him a
prenup and then they got married too
quickly so she was going to give him a
post note he called the lawyer from
australia
called her up and fired her
you'll hear the testimony from the
lawyer as you go through those three
days of australia some pretty horrendous
things happen to her he rips off her
nightgown he has her jammed up against a
bar he has hurled bottles and bottles at
her he has dragged her across the floor
on the broken bottles in the liquor he
has punched her he has kicked her he
tells her he's gonna kill her he hates
her he's pounding at her pounding her
and then he penetrates her with a liquor
bottle that's the johnny depp that
you're going to hear about in this case
now heard's lawyers say that depp
actually defamed her when he called her
a perjurer and a hoax artist but depp's
lawyers say depp never said that those
were things that his former lawyer said
and he believed those things to be true
now depp's lawyers called the first
witness on the first day of the trial
that was johnny depp's older sister she
testified about how they were both
physically abused by their mother when
they were children and that the mother
was also physically abusive to their
father and that that was somehow a way
that he learned to cope with abuse
during the marriage to amber heard a
testimony ongoing this trial will last
for six weeks brian
thanks angenet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney julie
reynoldman and co-host terry austin
julie what impression were you left with
the case after you heard both the
openings from the defense and the
prosecution
so i think it's a fascinating case but i
admit i was scratching my head a little
bit after listening to the openings and
the reason i am is i am shocked shocked
that we are in a position where johnny
depp is this case i don't see at the end
of the day what he has to gain
all this is going to do as far as i'm
concerned is potentially expose more and
more about his drug use his alcohol use
and keep in mind brian that when we talk
about abuse abuse isn't always just
hitting someone abuse can be texts abuse
can be aggravated harassment abuse can
be breaking things and i think if the
jury hears that they're going to accept
that she's telling the truth and that's
all they need to be victorious even if a
jury finds that at times she was abusive
too so i'm not sure why he decided to go
down this road it'll be interesting to
see
what comes as the days go on
especially after the fact how's it gonna
hurt or help his image uh when we hear
all these facts about him terry how much
of this case just boils down to
credibility and also to some degree how
much the jury likes amber or johnny
you know it's all credibility it is
literally dep's word against heard's
word and what that jury believes
everyone is saying both the defense and
the prosecution in their opening
statements that it is this op-ed what
was said in this op-ed this is whether
it was true and whether it was
defamatory whether or not their damages
but it's more than that to prove whether
or not these statements are true to
prove whether or not there's been abuse
they are going to get into the details
of that marriage and so i think we're
going to see a lot of flinging back and
forth and it's going to be very
salacious indeed absolutely
what did depp's lawyers tell the jury
about when the marriage ended and why is
that so important
well it's very interesting because
johnny depp's mother passed away on may
20th of 2016. they say he went to their
apartment that they shared the next day
to collect some clothes and told amber
heard you know i want out he said he was
going to europe to travel with his band
and tour
they say that basically she filed for
divorce like really right after that and
then uh six days later five you know
five or six days later she shows up at
the courthouse to file a domestic
relations restraining order and they
said
you know she didn't have bruises the day
he came to the apartment but she somehow
had marks on her face the day she filed
for the restraining order six days later
so it's some weird timing and we're
apparently going to hear testimony from
police about that all right we'll see
how that goes with that timing of that
incident thank you very much for your
reporting agent still ahead on law and
crime daily an idaho judge makes a
ruling on laurie valodebel's competency
to stand trial but first witness
testimony begins as anthony tote stands
trial for the quadruple murder of his
wife children and family dog
[Music]
welcome back we're learning more details
about a deadly subway shooting in
brooklyn new york co-host terry austin
joins us now with the newest information
on this developing story terry
brian more than 10 people were shot on
tuesday morning when a suspect threw
smoke bombs in a subway car and began
firing it happened just before 8 30 in
the morning near the 36th street subway
station in sunset park that's when
police say an african-american man
opened fire he's described as being five
foot five with a heavy build officials
say the gas mask was on him and a green
construction type vest was what he was
wearing investigators also say multiple
people were trapped and eventually hit
by bullets both on the train and the
platform at a press conference tuesday
afternoon
new york officials announced multiple
agencies are investigating
i want to begin by assuring the public
that there are currently no known
explosive devices on our subway trains
and this is not being investigated as an
act of terrorism at this time
we can also report that although this
was a violent incident reportedly we
have no one with life-threatening
injuries as a result of this case
this investigation is only hours old so
please note this information is subject
to change
ordinary ordinary new yorkers woke up
in anticipation of a
relatively normal day
they've left their homes
enroute to school
and route to their jobs
into a normal day as i mentioned
that sense of tranquility and normalness
was disrupted brutally disrupted
by an individual
so cold-hearted
and depraved of heart that they had no
caring about the individuals that they
assaulted
as they simply went about their daily
lives
officials ask anyone with information to
come forward by calling the phone number
listed on your screen back to you brian
and in florida testimony continues in
the trial of anthony toad a former
physical therapist charged with killing
his wife three young children and family
dog in their vacation home
forty-five-year-old tote faces four
murder charges and an animal cruelty
charge in connection to the deaths of
his wife megan children alexander tyler
and zoe and the family dog breezy who
were all killed in december of 2019.
toad is accused of drugging his family
with benadryl before stabbing and
suffocating them prosecutors say tote
lived alongside their bodies for weeks
after their deaths monday afternoon the
prosecution began its case calling
simple forensic technicians deputies
from the osceola sheriff's office and
the 911 dispatcher who took a call from
the defendant's sister before the bodies
were found that call asking for a
welfare check on her family was played
for the jury
hi i don't know who i need to speak with
i'm curious if i can have a wellness
check done
i had actually called on december 29th
and i had an officer go out
because i was concerned uh my my brother
and his family they had all been sick
but there's actually been um
more
developments there's actually an acid
and i
just in in conversations with my sister
um you know my sister-in-law was making
a comment about and we just kind of put
it all together about um
basically the world ending on the 28th
and nobody has talked to them um nobody
physically talked to my sister-in-law
since the 26th of december and my
brother has stopped texting as of monday
so i don't know if there's a way that
somebody can go out they have their
renting a place they're actually being
evicted from that property um but that's
the last place that we know that they
were supposedly at that they have a
condo that's right around the corner as
well
coming up on law and crime daily hear
from both sides as closing arguments are
presented in the trial of ex-olympian
michael barrisson plus the latest
developments in the so-called doomsday
duel will lori valodebel and her husband
stand trial will be scheduled on time
[Music]
welcome back an idaho judge makes a
startling ruling as laurie valodebel of
the so-called doomsday duo is now fit to
stand trial on monday judge stephen
boyce ruled valodebil is competent to
stand trial after months of delays in
the case valodebo and her husband chad
dabo faced charges in the deaths of her
two children jj valo and tyler ryan as
well as daebel's first wife tammy the
pair were dubbed the doomsday duo for a
shared belief in the end of days the
couple was married in 2019 just weeks
after dabell's wife mysteriously died in
her sleep then valodebel's youngest
children went missing tammy dabo's body
was later exhumed and in june 2020 the
remains of jj and tyler were recovered
on chad dabo's property for nearly a
year there were questions surrounding
valor dabel's ability to stand trial
after she was initially deemed
incompetent this new ruling means the
trial against valodebel and her husband
can go forward right now they're said to
be tried together in january 2023
valodebo is set to be arraigned next
week
julie do you think that with laurie
valodeva competent we may see a change
in her defense maybe even a plea now
that she can work alongside her
attorneys
so brian that's obviously the million
dollar question and you know obviously i
i can't read tea leaves but my guess is
you're never going to see a plea from
her unless unless
she's had such a change of heart after
becoming competent that she decides to
cooperate and potentially testify
against her husband that's the only
scenario where i see her pleading guilty
but keep in mind being competent to
stand trial is not necessarily the
largest of bars and so she's still not
may and and likely is quite mentally ill
and unstable and so i think those
factors are going to play very deeply
into what happens in the future whether
she goes to trial pleads cooperates or
or any of the above all right we'll see
what happens uh terry does this put
their cases back on track or are there
other legal hurdles to get over before
trial
well brian the trial's on track for the
moment but i do anticipate that we are
going to see so many motions that might
just very well take the trial off track
so we're probably going to see renewed
motion to sever the case perhaps we
might see a renewed motion to change the
venue i know we're going to see multiple
evidentiary motions so that we can keep
out some evidence if i were on the side
of chad i would be arguing that anything
that was discovered in his backyard
should not be introduced that the search
wasn't warranted and that kind of
evidence as far as he's concerned and as
far as she's concerned you know she's
just got to hope that the evidence
doesn't come in against her because it
looks really strong at this point yeah
and still the question is are they going
to be tried together in 2023 or is
someone going to point the finger at the
other we don't know but of course we'll
give you updates here on the law and
crime daily as they come in when we come
back the case is starting to wind down
in the olympian attempted murder trial
still ahead on law and crime daily hear
the closing arguments from both sides
[Music]
welcome back after more than a week of
testimony closing arguments are
presented in the olympia murder
attempted murder trial out of new jersey
defendant michael barrasson is charged
with two counts of attempted murder for
shooting lauren canarac and firing a
shot at her then boyfriend robert
goodwin in 2019. defense attorneys say
barristone feared for his life at the
time of the shooting and suffered from
mental health issues even sleeping in
his stable up to the event
ahead of the shooting bearish zone a
former olympian was training canarac in
dressage writing as she lived on his
property in the days leading up to the
shooting a string of 9-1-1 calls were
made by both parties barris owns saying
he tried to evict kanarak and kanarak
saying she was being harassed during
closing arguments defense attorneys told
jurors the prosecution had not met their
burden of proof
the only evidence as to how the shooting
occurred comes from both cataract and
goodwin
the investigation starts and stops
with them
it stops with robert goodwin
pointing to michael barrisson and saying
he's the shooter
two people
who i had indicated in my opening and i
believe the evidence has confirmed
have a motive to lie
who have changed their stories left
important things out poor important
facts
and have now
walked into this courtroom
put their hand on this bible
looked you all in the law in the eyes
and lied to you
the prosecution countered in its closing
arguments saying defense attorney did
not show enough evidence to prove an
insanity defense
you still have to decide whether that
delusional disorder
made it such that he didn't know the
nature and quality of his acts or that
he didn't know what he was doing was
wrong and the judge is going to tell you
you do not have to rely just on the
doctors for this you can rely on your
common sense you can rely on the other
evidence that you heard
what did the other evidence show
all the same things that established
that the defendant wanted to kill
show that he knew the nature and quality
of his actions what's the trigger
what makes it on august 7th 2019
defendant hasn't seen lauren or rob at
all that day
what makes the delusion at that point
click turns off his memory and makes him
say i have to go kill or be killed
this delusion of fear has now driven me
to have to go and kill
it's an interesting way to put up the
kind of clicking moment but julie with
everything you've heard did the defense
prove barisone was insane or has an
insanity defense when it came to
shooting at can iraq and goodwin
and notice i'm flicking my eyes and
moving my head because you know look it
there is a mental illness there i don't
think there's any question i think they
established that did they establish that
that defect um
rises to the level of an insanity
defense i don't think so remember they
bear the burden uh by preponderance of
the evidence i think there's no question
that he was ill i'm not sure that
they're able to establish that he didn't
understand right from wrong remember
this is kind of a hodgepodge of
self-defense
uh insanity uh defense so it'll be
interesting how the jury kind of takes
each one apart to come to a conclusion
as to what they think is the right
verdict yeah tara i don't know if a
defense is actually going to be provided
to the jury i don't know self-defense i
don't think self-defense is going to
make it and i agree with julie so
what verdict are you expecting in this
case
well listen the judge has already thrown
out the self-defense he said he's not
going to charge the jury and he said
you're not going to mention it in your
closing so we won't hear much of that
but i think we will hear a lot of that
medical evidence and i think there was
sufficient evidence to show that he was
either insane or that he certainly had a
mental deficit and that it did affect
his judgment and his ability to tell
right from wrong so i think we're not
going to see an acquittal and i think we
may not even see a conviction i think we
might
see a hung jury here i don't know if all
12 of those jurors are going to be able
to get together and have a consensus so
i'm sort of predicting that we might see
a misdraw here look there were over 50
witnesses and it was 11 days of trial a
lot of evidence to go through and i
don't think we're going to see all of
those jurors coming to the exact same
conclusion
all right we'll see how it goes and
we'll see how that split goes if it is a
hung jury well thank you julie and thank
you terry as always and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you